boom
james gunn is sick
he has boundless imagination
you're watching the master at what
he is in his element in this genre
james is such a visionary director okay
great such a new take on an established
franchise let's get it
the movie's gigantic i mean it really is
the biggest movie i've ever made
and i wanted to do most of it
practically and we did
stepping into he said it's crazy james
he's really a genius
he's really good at creating an
atmosphere where things come to life
[Music]
he took the camera and the actors to a
place where the audience would be like
this is really happening
it's that visceral you're hearing the
explosions you're smelling the gun
powder and that just ups the ante
leaving your arms
like that that's it okay great james's
specialty
is unique characters nothing like a
bloodbath to start the day
and surreal environments we shot in
panama
everywhere you looked it was incredible
it's brightly colorful and beautiful
i remember thinking it's just gonna look
wicked on screen
this is the man who makes films that
blow people's minds
when it comes to visual spectacle but
then it's all grounded in character
development
sprinkled with humor
he does throw polka dots at people
superhero movies should be fun
and should be bonkers that is your hand
very good he knows how to do the comedy
things the hahas and all the actions the
boom booms
and combine those to make a nice taster
snack of dopeness
oh yeah [ __ ] you in your underwear
i was emboldened by warner brothers
faith in me to be able to do whatever we
wanted with this movie this is great it
is
everything i want it to be
yo is this a dog i'm gonna go with
afghan hound is it a werewolf slapped me
next to a werewolf
[Music]
you